the house
team deathmatch
you have your orders bnd weapons free
[Music]
uh
so
[Music]
huh
xd
[Music]
enemy spy plane inbound
huh
in bed
[Music]
throwing frag
true
[Music]
uh
three
[Music]
that's his arm
good
[Music]
fragmentation
wrong frag
enemy spy plane inbound
check your targets
[Music]
care package available for tasking
hostile care package inbound
hostile attack helicopter inbound
oh
trophy systems
multiple hostile spy planes detected
multiple enemies
[Music]
fragmentation
your pace
lethal out
[Music]
so
that's the wrong outcome bnd rendezvous
with exfiltration team
no plan survives contact with the enemy
you